this capsule we will see the syntax of
the logic of the first rank so as one
saw in logic the first rendering to two
aspects that we will have to explore for
to be able to make inference
logic actually in this capsule if this
that we look at and it's specifically the
syntax to know how were we
will be able to express in logical forms
first-rate facts that darkens and
that they describe our our
environment
so I started with a course
fast of the different concepts that we are going
have to review logical first flight
so an expression in logic of the
first round
we will call it a formula a formula
is going to be actually a combination of a
or multiple credits cases predicates
in front of a handset using
logical connectors to help or a site
web or quantifies catr as he
exists or for all prices says core
every medicine from yves to
describe forgiveness of the facts that are going to be
true or false so in fact a predicate goes
determine what something that is
true and then in the game it's some
thing that they actually do it at the
negation of a predica and so all these
small clubs will correspond to
relationships between objects most of the
time sometimes the decrypts predicates
other objects even often do it
predicts that to see arguments that will
match objects objects in
question
sell cries using terms and the
baths at the port is a two three
things are of a constant like in
the example of rome caesar or marcus
would be constants
it'll be able to be a variable either in
kitchen held tiny like x or y
but in this case it is not specified
not exactly what the object is
in question so we will be able to make
reasonings of it existed x or for
all and there
and he also possibly see as
term of the functions applied to others
terms so we could wonder about
we could refer to for
markus in the left leg of marcus and
so the function because that's what
would be left leg that take a
argument that must be reborn a term
who in this example if it's marcus is
it would refer to the left leg
of marcus then obviously all that is
near the canto logical pass quantifies them
sensors and terms we will describe them
using symbols the symbols we
will use I'm going to use a
certain convention among others by name
for some of these symbols by
example for constants
it could be a number or a word and
the first letter of the world on the way
normal the soul and in capital letters
to distinguish variables that are going to
be raised to tiny then
functions that will also be described
stop the first letter
normally will use a letter
tiny and a function is going to have some
arguments and gold later the wind say
more about the relationship of the function and
his arguments when also we talked
close to the body noticed that a price
of the cac is not a theme
so constants and functions
are terms the variables too but
not the predicates the predicates by
against in the air have looked a lot like
to functions that happens to be a word
then often see parentheses that goes
identify
surrounded the arguments of the predicted one
may have against the prices of kop
blood without arguments so we max
that no argument to the predicates so
the number of arguments is of a
function or a predica that's what we
will call to stop him and noticed that
it's very important the predicates this does not
are not functions ie that
it is
conceptually incorrect to think or
to see the predicates as sandy
functions that they return values
binary really do not know if he plays a
role that is fundamental and that is
different predicates play a role
different fundamental and we will have to
treated differently from control
predica it's not a term while a
function it's a term
and when we see other examples
this notion of rest more so the role
fundamental predicates actually it's
that they are at the base of the forms a
formula it's a combination of
predicates his good combinations of
then function variables often
for the variables
we will use tiny letters
only one letter for reference
barriers for the symbol to master
finally the connectors for the
negation will use this symbol too
its symbols there for the conjunction the i
this symbol for blue disjunction or
is this symbol if the arrow for
involvement and quantifies them catr the
to master everything upside down and
for the church it's an e per year but
reflecting then we talked about term so
constants are terms and the
variables are also terms
when I speak of a term of care I
speaks of a constant or a variable
I can also talk about a function that
will be applied to one or more
terms so the application of a function
terms will also be a term to
to take otherwise if we had several
terms t1 until tng we have a
function that will equip one who take
arguments that inherited from nf2 t1
until tnc at the cemetery so for example
john strand term because it's a
constant well john's father so the
function by applying to the constant
jones is also a term by x is a
theme too or 6 x here and that's a
variable and then father whose prat in
input as argument a term since
father of the ex is also a term on
could scare you to lose
xcom this would probably refer
grandfather of x in a base of
knowledge
in fact the functions could the
avoid by defining a constant for
every possible argument of the function
so if we had a father function and
then we had two observations john
and louis comes for and instead just
define a constant father john then a
constant father louis ok so that would be
another way of modeling a
environment we have john and louis then
everyone loses we could just have some
separate constants for john's father
and the father louis by cons we're going
to lose is the possibility of reasoning
in general with variables on
the relationship of these different functions
something that matters that we can
do with functions it is noted
something like that his brother ex y
implies that ego eg ex loses ex
let's not think about it that's what said
what it says is that the 6 x and y are
brothers
but we do not have to do x so here it is
it's really a function also
by experts from there are equal and
notice if ego his brother are
predicates since it is they are part
of a formula he has a formula where we have
combined the predicate his brother ego had
among other things, the implication for
use the quantifies catr universal
and for all here so his ego brother are
prices said here while fathers
are functions in this case and
that's why we can put them in
argument to a loan of the body one does not
could not put as argument of
close to the body another predicts like
precisely because a price says core
it's not just a function that
return ball is really something
separate thing and whose trip with
this formula we are able
finally to reason so
on the function of the father in
determining that his name the price of the co
his brother xy ben actually is that the
by ex no direction and tasting
discussion had had fathers john
beyrle yes and if next there will be done
their listeners
it was necessary to have separate predicates
for every possible value excess of y
so every possible constant for who
refers to the father of each
constant every person in our
environment
so now for non formulas
a little more in detail so the
simplest formula it's a single
predica so a predicate is a formula
is specifically if we have t1 terms
until tn since we learned from the cope
who at n
argument that is an inheritance from
hate and well p2 t1 until tn it's a
formula is the simplest formula
now if we negate the
conjunction the disjunction or
the formula implication we get
also a formula that is to say that are
the alfa-beta form well the negation of
alpha so no alpha or alpha and beta or
alpha or beta and alpha implies beta
are all formulas also the
universal quantification the
existential quantification of a formula
or it is a formula that is to say that
if alpha and a formula I know that
it's a variable
if I write for all x alpha and he
exists x alpha so these are two of
things there are actually formulas so
to stir up that does it said that
for any value of x half way should
so in the must have probably
a predicate with precisely
inside the variable x so that's it
could be I do not know me person x
lx to be that so for all ex
nobody is that it's true that everything
all the possible constants
of the possible item x is a person
that there are six alfassa says that he
exists a value of x as predicted
that alpha is true
since we have operators we have to
determine their priorities
so when priority is the negation
survival of and where and involvement
what that means among other things
that the negation of alpha and beta that
actually corresponds to negate
before of alfort then of his
to have the conjunction of the negation of
alpha and beta so that does not fit
to his something different
it does not correspond to that because the
denial to priorities on the
conjunction for oneself this is an example
who could do other examples
with the priorities of operations are
similar concepts that's already seen
probably in programming language
the notion of priority is used
parentheses the same way as in
arithmetic expressions in
just programming to properly determine
control their application of
different operations
and in terms of quantifying they
will apply to the whole formula to
their right so among others for all
explains sue qxc implies fx that would be
equivalent to that here ie for
all x in parenthesis all these formulas
there and that would not be equivalent to for
all shipped x or would return it the
parenthesis here or what is it implies
an x so that's not the good
interpretation of this here this is the
good interpretation
one way to see that in fact is that
to say that quantify them an order of
priority when prioritizing the most beautiful
is finally some equivalence that
you probably already know that
you already learn from other classes
alpha or beta it's actually equivalent to
negation of the negation of alfort and
the negation of beta is because we
can distribute the negation to
inside the parenthesis is the
negation applied to a
conjunction becomes the disjunction of the
negation of the two arguments ie
that the negation of all this is the
negation of the negation of alpha so
it's alpha or the negation of the
negation of beta so that happens beta
we did have alpha or beta
equivalent here is another
alpha equivalency implies beta is
equivalent to the negation of alpha or
beta that's really something that
you have seen to sell it's a course of
discrete mathematics for example and
finally there exists v alpha so exile
a life value such as alpha is
equivalent to the negation of to find
the negation of alpha so to say that there
exist a life pain such as alpha
it's the same as saying that he
does not exist that it's not true that for
to open you do not have to do it and so
the interest of these equivalences there
is that it converts all
dysfunctions in a conjunction of
to remove all the implications for
get a disjunction that she can
to be converted once again into a
conjunction and then this equivalent ci
allows to eliminate all quantifying
existential to get some
quantifying universal and for all then
let's do a little exercise to see
concretely how can we
take defy natural language then
first-order logical formulas
so let's go back to our example of Rome
in first order logic
marcus is a person one could
write it as being marcus the price of
co mercus in parenthesis of which pardon the
predicted as a parenthetical person
marcus so here marcus is a constant
that we have defined who will be referring to
the person marcus and then nobody
is going to be a price of the case we still have
once defined so we use symbol
people to do to do
reference to the fact that marcus is a
nobody
then from his mark us is a firefighter
the way the logical screen of the
first of all it is to take back our
same constant marcus so we speak
still from the same person who's called
marcus and then give it an argument
a new loan of the body that we are going to write
pompey we want symbols the word pump
and one to make reference to the fact that
something in our our
environment is pumped starts only if
marcus is well and truly pumped according to this
description
all firefighters are romans to a
way of writing at the logis de prades
say that for all x firefighters of x
involves Roman dx
actually if all the pumps and a
its romans that means to be
pumped implies to be Roman and that's
true for all firefighters peace is
so we add it for all to our
implication on x and then we put the
variable x in the arguments of predica
Roman Pompeii their marks and if we have
defined another close to the human body that
refers to the fact that something
be Roman Caesar is a leader
when we add a constant 6 years
then have defined a new a new
symbol for the predicate forgiveness a
new club loan with symbol
leaders who is referring to the fact
that something is leaders so
we are saying that caesar the
constant season and leaders
everyone is loyal to someone
so we start by defining a
loyal pass price x / y that says that x and
loyal to it's the definition when we
is on the table here skin our predica
loyal
everyone so for any excess
it's everyone is loyal so x
for all x royal x to someone so he
exists for each person does exist
a person for a person there for
every person x such as x and loyal to y
so such as loyal of xy
all Romans are loyal to six has
rolled a bit more complicated then for
all x we ​​have that Roman x implies either
loyal excisors or to ix Caesar so
indeed we did well
encapsulated in first-order logic the
does that if one is Roman glassey
implies either that x and loyal to Caesar
so loyal and Caesar or x to icesar so
so exciting more dense than if we still
introduced a new cock loan that is
hate that refers to the fact that a
object x more hate another object there dancing
deposit of the variable x then the ski and
alice and caesar so we use the
constant six years to reference
to the fact that Caesar here who hoisted the
same thing as the Caesars here which is
leading the only leaders that a
nobody and that's murder are those
to which she is not loyal then this
that it says if we will read the formula
seems logical to pre-roll for everything and
for everything and greek
if we have nobody x and Greek leaders
and murdered xy no that translates well the
so you leave alone
leaders so that's referring to
leaders that a person has
to murder so we have to the person x who
are trying to murder murdered xy sa
reference to a person to some
thing
an object x that kills Greek then
putting person x make sure that x is
a person and now what is
murdered in what is described here
he's an officer so we're going to have
also here leaders of y
then nobody x and Greek leaders and
murdered xy implies we do not have the
negation of loyal xy and so as one
had in the app too are those
to which she is not loyal so the
person who did
the assassin is not loyal to the
person to there
in fact here we do rather the leader
Greek this is what was specified
in the formula here and finally marcus
tried to murder Caesar well we
had taken it had been defined the predicted that
pretty cynical that refers to
Something
x who is murdering something Greek
when if we have outright that marcus has
tried to murder Caesar will have done
murder that refers to the fact of
six to try to sign so that's
marcus who are trying to murder Caesar
we call Marcus pardon murdered
Marcus Caesar so that's how we
would do that would be a way we could have
choose different symbols for them
different prices of the co in too so they
go to certain variations if it had
been you who made this translation
the from the national language to the
first order logic this is a
reasonable way to translate all
facts here in the form of a base of
first-order logic knowledge